[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Ericson alongside Gregory Alba I said your
name for said my name how you doing good don't
woman expain my name well now do it every time
all right nobody likes hearing you go over
and over Gregory ala everyone's like yeah we
know it's better if I do it I rarely say my name
they're going to leave it they're going to leave
it in the comments he doesn't need to say his
name cuz he's so famous leave a comment I mean
you guys can join in and be like yeah t should
always say his name because she's cooler and
also don't forget to ring the bell the B we're
watching 47 MERS down I forgot to say that at
the top oh my God we're watching that and it has a
shark and Manny Moore in it I just remembered our
friend Roxy strier she's close friends with
the director of this movie really yeah that
means we got a crap on it so we don't look like
we're sucking up you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah we don't need we're not going to suck up Roy
CU she's got a cool friend who directs movies Roy
to the director to the director right the direct
we don't know the know the director we don't know
their name but we're not going to suck up to them
we'll tell you that much okay yeah sucker but you
know you know who we will suck up to the super
super sexy re because you guys are on patreon and
we love you so much thank you for joining I mean
you guys get to watch and sync up with your full
own copy me watch me and gray we watch 47 meters
down basic almost all of it when you become super
sexy and you get on the patreon Greg and John
offer exclusive watch alongs and highlights on
patreon so you got to get on there to get the
exus a shter way of saying it brilliant yeah
right and I didn't even look at the page look at
the page because I if I did I would have said read
out loud nope nope no I took go away we this intro
is long okay we got to get to it 47 me down let's
go
oh man we're getting right to it we're
already underwat wonder how down we
are at this point how many meters
you think we are at this point oh
meters this movie is dark yeah it's going to
look just like this the whole time
with our reflection right in the
television okay liking that
music yeah it's dread heavy
whoa that's pitch black right
now right now I see some
bubbles oh my god oh thank God well it is
throwing you into the abyss now I'm with
it oh that is a cool opening actually
showing you just how terrifying the
the yeah while we vacation up above
oh and it's got a drink holder cool
Johannes Roberts let's give
it up johanes let's give it
up let's give it up man Johannes
you know you ever need an [Music]
actress oh that's who was down there oh cool
reveal they were they're just in a pool I love
it neat shk got you are serious look what
you did I'm going to go back to the room I
told steart I'd give him a call yeah what's mny
morbin up to that one show that makes you cry
every episode when you watch it very popular
once some emies Ah that's clever the wine the
wine making the blood effect I get what you're
doing give it up for joannis Roberts Direction
bra it's called foreshadowing thank you so much
for bringing me on vacation it's going to be the
best time ever ain't nothing bad going to happen
here today do it Stuart is missing out I'm way
more fun anyway you are that look made it seem
like there's trouble in the water nicely their
relationship nicely done this relationship
is sinking oh what's wrong what wrong Lisa
it's Stuart I lied about what Stuart I lied
about why Stuart isn't on this trip what do
you mean he's not working he left me he left
to be Kate oh wow I really called that you're
good at predicting seconds for their reveal
terrible he got bored he actually said that
yeah that's cruel and then I thought if I came
on this trip and I came away with you and I had
fun and I showed that I could be fun somehow you
would come back that's sad well are you taking
social media photos to show just how great
your life is post breakup you and I are going
out it's 1:00 in the morning please said it's
Mexico you and I are the only ones who aren't
out come on yeah dude it's safe for two white
women to go venturing around Mexico at one in
the morning a.m. come on have some fun post
breakup fun oh you brought two boys back to
the beach with you huh best night I could be
here all night girl is a morning they really
keep establishing this is a great day it was
bad in the beginning but it's gotten good
Lisa you look desperate you look desperate Lisa
Lisa social media photos like he said oh oh oh
oh down ni rough guys are inane seriously you
have to try we do it almost every weekend it's
amazing scuba diving 25 foot gr West they come
right up to your cage 25 never seen anything
like it like $100 each we we know Taylor is like
a friend of ours no d That's sheep yeah get in
there swim with some sharks you're only down 5
m totally safe exactly it's like you're going
to the zoo except you're in the cage yeah and an
underwater sweet sauce better know so you could
just think of the photos they won't be the type
of photos that a boring person can take boom he
called it look who's having fun now with great
whites yeah that's right [Music] okay I would
die to get a selfie with a great white in the
background oh me too I'm sure we could Photoshop
it no I want it to be real yeah wanted to say I
had a really good night tonight me too yeah yeah
have fun come on kiss him come on and hisy girl
oh God no it's okay it's fine see you tomorrow
tomorrow for sure come on oh how upsetting
oh girl just been she was trying to make out
with that guy from the night to the morning to
the next night and still won't kiss oh okay oh
yeah that's what I'm talking we go whoa whoa whoa
Kate I don't know about this it'll be fun hola CH
hey how's it going hey how are you I don't know
who the actress opposite of Manny Moore is but I
really like the two of them together they feel
like really believable as friends yeah I agree
like they've been friends for a while I just heard
horror stories about Taurus going on these Shady
trips and Stuart even anything steuart has to say
is invalidated now he's he's dead to you girl come
on now hola H I like him Matthew MO Dean you both
know how to scuba dive right yeah yeah MH MH girl
you going to have a panic attack underwater
if it's a first time you put on scuba GE all
right well welcome aboard that sounds horrify
have you done it I've never done it well I got
certified as a rescue scuba diver cuz I was a
dolphin trainer what oh man well now your life
is way more exciting here when I was 20 and 21
y'all oh so like 40 years ago exactly a lifetime
ago first time I got in the pool scuba gear on I
was like no I can't well look at this janky ass
boat you look like Ikea chairs on the on the
you look like you're modern-day Pirates going
to have the time of your life I'm
scared damn this water is gorgeous
yeah damn they do not clean that boat
cast Matthew mod in anything and he just
seems suspicious this is it yeah this
is it's pretty unnerving shoing
time hungry oh boy e feeding
time I don't think I'd want to
do this I thought it was legal
to CH the water think I should Callie CH Mr CH
hello God oh hickey I wouldn't want
to do it in my here with this Rusty
Cage yeah they just put that down smell it
should be here soon I do think it is doing a
good job in building tension I prefer the movie
when it doesn't have music playing yeah I agree
a sense of the atmosphere and the mood there look
where there hey it's Ming fast oh my God this is
amazing pull it together Lisa I'm
sorry I'm sorry don't be mad at me
I can't you're not going to make
Stuart jealous with photos inside
the boat's B I started to become
manipulative have fun Bo don't
slip that cage looks so unreliable yeah
that's what I'm saying it's Rusty as
hell so Rusty like and those Cliffs look
like they're plastic at top I'd be like
no I wouldn't even be the captain
just standing on top of this
cage how would you know for sure the shark is
in their proximity where they can see it yeah
the waves like under like the Rippling
maybe my God it's huge oh well let's get
you suited up now I'm really nervous you are
mhm I'm shooting bricks wow Johannes Roberts
was respectful enough to not show them like in a
bikini right give it up for respect give it up for
respect waited 20 whole minutes for that shot
and uh didn't get it calm down okay yeah I'm
okay good that's it okay I should have worn my
headband wear a headband every video one time
I don't wear a headband where a character has a
headband he's one uping you right now check your
air you should both have 200 bar she's like down
to 100 200 that's your air she going to run out
of air in 2 seconds she going to go down there
and have a panic attack if you get any pain in
your ears you just need to equalize what is that
til your head back in does that really work well
it'll pop the pressure in your ears it builds up
up oh cool trust me once you're down there you're
not going to want to come back up right care it's
great you're going to love it down there next be
careful I know I saw the trailer years ago but
I don't remember anything about what's supposed
to happen me neither miles away since if you're
frightened or weak track you down great pep talk
sir I I want to go on do this with that guy right
there yeah right instill as much fear into me as
possible before I do right before you got got to
go down and get it what are we doing Kate smile
put it around your wrist girl shouldn't they
be in the cage as it's descending I mean we're
switching it up now I guess with these oh okay
the foot it's tension building is what we're doing
here once you take the first
breath in the suit like that
there's no way she's just going to
be breathing normally it feels so
weird ah creepy H never done anything like
this of the sort this is really unsettling
for me ah I like that obscuring the vision
even more down we go You Can See For Miles
Kate look at the fish do you see all the fish
my hands would not be on the bars hell no I'm
good actually I can't see any sharks
all right well just be p we're going
to add a little bit more CH to the water
now no that's horrible I would just be
happy with the fish yeah it kind of takes
your breath away well that's not what you
want what is it coming it's
going to come right from the
bottom I love that they're capturing The
Wonder of it though Che hi take me back
steart take a picture of me wait no that's
why you're supposed to put the rubber band on
your wrist you got to go get that awesome
that is actually scary as hell God oh my
God that is
scary would the shark have eaten the cell phone I
don't think so this is amazing uhoh I would hate
this so much I would not not do it I have decided
I would think it's cool but we all know Chum's
going to get in the water he's going to start to
get feisty and they're going to be like where's
that food at I can't believe how close they are
I dare you to touch him no no why would you do
that you don't do that steart can't even see that
there's two of them they're so fast you touch one
he can bite your the other one can bite your arm
off girl oh he definitely likes to look at you
of course I think the cage just dropped a little
bit no no it's the Wench mechanism it's it's fine
it just slipped a little bit uhhuh I'm sure it's
nothing we're fine okay are you crazy this is when
I go up would like to come back up now please
all right listen stand by sorry said come on
oh no the shark's going to knock them down or some
[__] right oh God I just don't feel safe in this
cage at least we got to see some sharks I mean I
guess so you guess so on is out can I go back down
again so it's the the rest of the movie them just
talking about it nope there's the rest of the
movie
sayara help whoa how many meters down
you think they're going to go oh my
God that is actually 47 that's actually really
scary oh no ah oh
[__] yeah girl don't be screaming your air
is gone that is a very no thank you oh my God
no that is rough you going so fast like you're
that would be so painful tilt your head back no
oh that's clever that foot out that's clever oh my
God damn that is so scary that is really scary oh
my god oh [__] holy junk that's terrifying that
is really really freaking scary oh my God oh my
goodness oh God if it keeps falling and it
breaks the cage oh god oh my god oh wait
till steuart hears about this maybe they can
find their camera down there yeah the shark
ate oh no the shark ate it that's right I remember
there drop hope for steart believing them [Music]
now that's a very unique claustrophobic situation
because it's open exposed yet you're trapped
oh damn is there mask filling up it's
probably cuz it's very cold down there
when you get lower like that shots are
weird what are we looking oh it's like
a extreme close of her face okay got
it a lot of it is very disorienting
[Music] close-ups oh no scary she's she got she
got injured my God and now we've got natural Chum
in the [Music] water 100% pure human Chum just
swimming around out there now look at me stop
stop you want an adventure hey girl
you got to calm down you're going
to lose all your air she's going to be at 50 in 5
minutes Andy Moore is really good at sell
in that Panic can you hear that tayor help
us hello this must have been a complicated ass
movie to shoot we must be just out of range of
transmission we've got to try and get my contct
with them how whoa the hell maybe we're just
a bit too deep maybe maybe if I swim up a tiny
bit him up nope this is a bad idea I would just
yeah but what about the Sharks you know what
I do I take my mask off and let myself drown
they know you're down there they know they
dropped you I won't leave you I promise I
promise girl sh stuck well good
you shouldn't be swimming up
there why would you attempt it's not they know
that they dropped I just feel like they're
going to eventually rescue us I mean do it do you
think these are the kind of guys who would go out
of their way to rescue them uh well if those two
guys want to get laid yes I can get it just give
me a second get your feet out of there I think I
can get out through these bars I need to take my
tank off though yes I need you to watch out for
me please be careful oh yeah she can definitely
fit through that part of it oh my God this is
just why are we doing this this is so scary I
would not do God this is insan this is really
really tense oh my God you are literally like
that's what they look for the movement I can't I
don't you do the exact movement to attract them
what are we going to do I'm going have to take my
mask off okay no no way I'm sure if you push it up
enough you could squeeze through if you're both
pushing I'm going to take it off and go through
and you're going to pass it right to me okay
if you can't get it back on again you'll drink
drown the two of them together are is very
very good yeah wow how horrifying girl get
that mask on Purge that water out of [Music]
there wow no Cuts that's great yeah that's
good you can like actually see the struggle
is freaking real okay we didn't see her but
the straps behind her head but that's fine uh
no is it a mislead is it a mislead oh God God
and now you don't have protection from the
cage cuz you can't get back in this is just
oh no blonde girl's totally dead like maybe
not right now but at some point in this movie
she's dead in five minutes let's keep a look
out okay well un yeah un try that good good
good damn I love the look of this
movie movie like the isolation
and the bubbles that's really it
looks really cool I think I have it
free is that a oh God it was just her I like
it's just her I was like oh my God is a shark
you got it you got it yeah good job Kate I'll
wait to go Kate heck yeah Kate oh my God I'm
going to see if I can reach the get get back
in the cage hurry please now she's going at the
top God that is that is terrifying po oh boy they
really know it is well captured it's really well
captured oh my God so scary God just that Bleak
desolation just not knowing how much further you
have to go K can you hear me it's it's K hello
you have to help us are you both okay yes good
yes how much air do you have in your tank um
I'm at 55 bar uhoh I need you to get back in the
cage immediately it's the only safe place from
the Sharks you understand Javier's coming down
to you now he's going to hook up the cage to our
spare wed feels like a a Universal Studios theme
park that you would go on don't try to race to the
surface you'll get the BS yeah I'm going back down
now promise me I'll come just stay in the cage
and reserve your air God I hate this oh God the
bubbles it's doing an excellent job on
capturing that Terror of a shark can come
at any moment right now like the amount
of tension I feel on my stomach is it's a
lot do we make a plot prediction right now
I feel like she's just going to see blood
coming down up in the cage and is gonna know
well Kate's dead I feel like Mandy she'll be
Mandy Moore will be isolated and then towards
the finale she will finally just like go I'm
gonna go make a break for it and oh yeah oh
she'll have to make a break for it because
she'll almost be out of hair cuz she's a
panic she's Miss panic I like that let's
see how this goes yeah that's Prett we need
Sur okay and by that point she'll be dead
blond girl it's over but I don't want her to
die I'd be happy if the movie let her live I
really like her character the other night at the
hotel what did you mean when you said that your
relationship was the only thing you were good
at you're always doing such fun stuff Kate I
could never compete with that my relationship
with Stuart was the one thing I had that you
didn't H we were never in competition maybe you
weren't I like how they wrote the younger sister
to be more like the older sister sister what do
you think steuart would say if he could see you
now Mandy Moore is so cute
and so pretty yeah men don't
Chaser what is that I think you know
exactly what that is it's the show
you've been waiting for oh my God that's
the boat's engine oh my God they've left
us they they wouldn't have left us okay
maybe it was a different vote I mean they
probably need something in order to they
have to probably leave to go back you
know my God this going out of
the cage I mean it's probably
better for their business if they just let them
[Music] die I love these wide shots over
there like tiny obscured oh yeah God byebye
in one bite right I'm scared can you hear me
hello there no no no I'm like someone answer
me
oh that that dreed man oh my
God hair all over my body is
God oh my God the chain oh God move the chain H
H oh my God that was that's really scary I
thought I was dead oh my God is the oh my
God oh my God that's so scary okay just going to
R it's going to get through oh my God he's going
to eat through the freaking cage who W that is
massive hole in your oh my gosh it almost broke
through the cage we're not safe here anymore this
is where they have to okay we cannot just swim up
no we can't we will get the bend it's nitrogen
bubbles in the brain the only way to go up is
to ascend slowly with a decompression stop for
5 minutes unprotected in open water well well
scripted they had to really learn their [__]
for this movie this movie is really selling me
on the possibility that they both die by the end
yeah yeah it says 80 bar I don't know what that
means this that means we have about 20 minutes
tops before we run out what what about you she's
see now I think she's just going to sacrifice
herself give her the oxygen well I think she's
just G to how many 10 she's used up a lot she
exerted her physical suffocate to death yeah
Javier is that Javier tell you I wouldn't be
talking I'd be doing straight up meditation
oh thank goodness yeah it's all going to pan out
Sarah right now that guy's going to get eaten is
he just diving without any protection there's got
to be no way you can't free dive that far or are
they just descending I you you can obviously but
like why wouldn't he have can they maneuver the
cage over to there like within it you know what
I mean oh like them push it yeah no they would
be out of they're already out of air I mean they
have lights on the cage you should be able to see
that uh-oh uhoh you see that it's just falling
well if he heard us why didn't need to Signal
we need to get that winch cable I love that
they've kept it just in their perspective
this whole time 17 bar you're almost out of
air don't remind her okay I'm yeah you got to
just swim up and you got to wait need to tell
me exactly what I need to do oh she's going to
rise to the occasion keep as close to the ocean
floor as you can sharks attack from blow so if
you keep to the floor you should be fine that
shark seem to be attacking right from the side
there this button inflates your BCD use it to go
up this button deflates it do not go straight up
you will die do you understand so she's just
going parallel to try to find the flashlight
guy I think so yeah okay that's good you're
doing so good okay keep your breathing slow
damn how do they film this this is really well
done it's awesome they build some weird set
it's probably just in the Universal [Music]
fool oh that is so scary that's awesome oh no
girl why you going fast like that oh trying
to get to a hiding spot yeah yeah okay I'm
just like frantic swimming oh God I think
it's gone skip too it's not gone [Music]
yeah Lisa what's going on Lisa are you okay
I I like how the sound design isn't overly
accentuated woo striking that bounce between
like Hollywood and realism with the shark yeah
like with the real sound and sometimes the
music the intensity comes in and then I kind
of like it though when it's like just the the
water and the breathing and the yeah like it's
scary as hell has a mood here I can see the
flashlight I can see the beam it's getting
close oh my God I what's wrong oh it's way
deeper got it I'm at the edge you some sort
of Cliff I can't see the ocean floor that is
horrifying oh God yeah God okay I can do this
no oh my god oh oh I am stressing out y'all oh
my God this flashlight is going to be like in
the water and no one's going to be attached
to it and I'm going to freak the F [Music]
out is she still within range to talk to her
sister I don't even I see it I guess so I see
it congratulations I found the flashlight
we didn't need a flashlight oh my God I am
so upset stay calm oh my God how FR just start
oh my God this is terrifying oh no I hate this
shot whoa oh my God this is wild I
hate everything about this there's
like a great trickery on your mind
where makes you think you're seeing
something so claustrophobic like
oh god oh my [Music] god oh no
what why did he just descend like by himself
down there knowing there's shark wait was
that that was her sister right no no no
no it was one it was the guy Kate Kate I
can hear you can you hear me why does
this have a 5.6 R IMDb this is really
well done I don't know it's like it's like
really well done I need you to b a rock or
something when you see the flashlight so I
know which way to go me that Echo hear you
Kate no no
he's got no hair oh you better
get away from that blood
girl okay all right all right okay good
thinking good thinking good thinking good
okay good thinking good thinking take everything
yes never leave a weapon behind good girl give me
the flashlight I'm going to swim back up and tell
them that we have to come up now be careful I'll
be right back you better go slow oh wow you super
Brave Taylor hello this is Hypnotic it's Lisa we
managed to attach the cable to the top of the
cage we need to come up right now jaier is dead
get back in the cage now I'm bringing you back
up I would start bringing it up as she's swimming
down
whoa oh my God is Kate like almost dead
there's excellent camera work here did
you hear that oh God is it going to
break on those oh There She Goes see
look we're starting to move maybe the shark
is going to knock it off there's like how
many sharks two well at least from when
we at the top I think there was two yeah
she's not going to make it she doesn't even
have enough air to go I'm so stressed out
44 hang on Kate we're at 36 M 35 it's too soon
it's too soon I don't like it oh God here we go
again you got to be sh Groundhog Day for real
oh my God this is just terrible maybe get out
of the cage and grab onto the Rope M okay get
on to the cage and grab onto the Rope yep yep
yep go oh my God oh my God this is not real Kate's
Dead Oh Kate's way dead Kate is dead right now
she's going to die now her sister's going to have
to make decision if she's going to oh my God it
just keeps getting worse we're running out of time
I've got to get a hold of Taylor Don't Leave Me
Kate I'm going to suffocate Kate's gonna suffocate
she's literally two minutes away from dying I'm
going to send down extra air tanks moving onto a
second tank is going to increase your chance of
nitrogen Narcosis dramatically okay make sure
that neither of you is behaving strangely or
hallucinating what Coast Guard they're sending
a team that's fully equipped for deep sea rescue
they'll be here in less than an hour less than
an hour yeah what what are you checking about
you think we got we got that kind of where's the
Coast Guard where was a coast guard the second the
thing broke off from your ship buddy catch catch
is Kate not going to make it back with them I mean
she is like she's practically dead this m i feel
like has been telling us this whole time Kate's
going to die God I feel like out of all them
Kate's going to die yeah okay come on Kate get
to the air great that light will not attract any
attention oh my God please don't die in the midst
of getting the air on I would just instantly grab
it and come back no no no she's got to hook up
now I said that's a flares good all we
have to do is wait for the Coast Guard
to arrive are they going to fall out
is it going to get what is this why we
get the close up the flares the flares are
going to go bye-bye can't get down [Music]
wow oh that's a cool shot the effects on the
sharks are great I was wondering if they use
like a shark head in that beginning shot when he's
biting the cage it looked awesome I'm going to
make a break through the cage no Kate no no no
don't move stay down stay down this is it open
the hatch come out Kate oh my god did he take her
head off and with the air and the flares oh God
God oh that's right she can't even
get to it yeah oh my God right her
freaking leg I forgot about that
Holy I am not going to die down
here she does have that gun though like how could
that t help her well I think as she's ascending
and then the shark's about to kill her she uses
the gun to shoot it shot the Shar survives cuz
it's a movie I mean I was thinking maybe she
shoots it to get the air and pull it back like
not shoot the tank like use the arrow to reel
it in somehow you know what I [Laughter] mean
actually that makes a lot more sense yeah girl
you got to use the thing and reach for the you
could do it damn it's right in sight there you
go Tera you're smart yes yeah baby smart cookie
Tera God girl I swear to God if they
make it to where she grabs it and it
shoots through a freaking hand I'm
going to die like I can't be doing
that right [Music] now oh okay no I no of course
oh she hooks it to the netting come
on now hook that netting oh wow this
is like when I spend $50 on those claw machines
yeah it's closer celebrate
[Music] progress there we go that'll hook around
the thing good job okay God grab it does she
know how to switch sh out that's the thing I'm
thinking I'm like I know her sister would but come
on God now it's time to hallucinate imagine
having a conversation with steuart in that
cage let's go there movie maybe he'd be like
oh you're fun now I'll take you back you're
interesting with a geving with the dead Sister
Lisa Kate Lisa are you there no way W okay I
thought that you were dead she's hallucinating
I managed to escape I'm hurt distracting more
sharks how much air do you have left dirty
bar oh this is good I don't know if it's real
or not she's going to have to I think it's
real yeah I I have no idea if it why would
they mention the hallucination thing though I'm
going to come and get you I'm going to come and
find you right now just swim up somebody's
got to just swim up the rolls are switching
she can inflate it so it lifts it up
use the air in there I hope it doesn't
pop the thing but okay good good good yeah yeah
[Applause]
yeah no
ow Kate keep talking to me please can you
see the be from my flashlight I see you
I see the flashlight yes okay I'm coming to
find you stay right where you are just grab
the spear in case would she have weapon
behind would she have been able to escape
that the shark you mean the shark yeah
yeah know I mean she could just be like
bitten and then you know injured that's
kind of all they do to humans they just
sort of like bite a limb and they spit them
out oh she is bleeding so much how how are
there not like a crap ton of sharks she said
she's like the sharks are surrounding me now
use the flare keate it'll help word off the
Sharks oh right would the flare ward off the
sharks or attract sharks I don't know yeah I
mean good question all my knowledge of sharks
comes from Cinema so I have no idea what an
actual shark is like I can hear you okay um
we are heading up now no it's not safe you
need to stay in the cage this guy in the cage
no if you ascend too quickly you're going to
get the B look at your Gau tell me what your
depth is Mom we're at 30 m dude I wouldn't
even concern myself we're at 20 M okay good
now you need to stay there for 5 minutes and
do a decompression stop you need to let the
nitrogen leave your blood Stam Kate's having
a lot leav her bloodstream right now 4 and
1/2 minutes we need to let another one hurry
oh no no no no got it got it just three more
minutes oh my God oh my God what
a reveal shot holy [__] that was
so [Music] scary oh my goodness
what do we do break for the Sur
wait what they're dropping the tanks
they that close already guess so
wow wow huh tiny bit of Hope oh my
goodness holy junk oh this would be so great
if the sharks ate them right here right I would
love it just killed him off right now okay
gra it oh God oh my God you guys suck they
suck so hard I hate I hate all of them so
much do they have like anything on them to
fight them off go do they have anything no
there goes your leg oh who did he get Mandy
right yeah yeah yeah oh
goodness oh God that is you got
to punch him in the nose I've
heard that actually doesn't work
yeah real hard I've have heard
that
oh my God oh my God
oh girl you're dead right no no no no no oh he
didn't even bite it fully he just kind of oh
my God oh my [Music] God oh at least you still got
your body parts oh never mind wrong about that she
like lose her whole leg she I mean I assume
so right unless they're like how strange uh
there she goes the old bubbles in the brain she
never made it to the surface she never made it
[__] A she never made it a man and
her sister's just what ly oh the whole
thing yep you were right yep oh we made it we made
it [Music] oh you're hallucinating
it's got funnye also like ju letter
are hallucinate I mean it we're way past like
the Coast Guard is here you are going to be
fine why do all these guys
die without any like real
protection the important part is she had the
character Arc in her mind true
it's a good story it's a good
hallucination that's [Music] tragic
sister still saved her one more let
this be a hallucination oh go just a Time Loop of
hallucinations I'm really
conflicted about the ending
is that it that's it right they're not going to oh
man my I I want to I want to talk about
the positives first okay let's let's do
it I am extremely conflicted
though about the choice of the
hallucination and now I'm wondering if that's
where the as I was it kept puzzling my mind
of why is this like IMDb rating like not as high
as because I was like this is a really well done
movie it's like really well done um but anyway all
right so why do you think the IMDb is lower it'll
because of the I I feel like it's i' to be the
thing about the not as much sharks or specifically
the way the ending went down I I Don't Know Jack
about the audience response on this movie I really
don't I don't know any specific so it is just a
guess um I will go into that later first things
first if you guys are listening to us on Apple or
Spotify real rejects podcast please what did they
do again well they're supposed to ra it it R it
is the D oh God rate it um thank God here we just
watched 47 meters down let's recap our our quick
experience here uh I went into this expecting a
cheese fest and it was anything but yeah it was
intense it was genuinely intense it felt grounded
and re like for someone who's never been scuba
diving even I know it's that exactly the same
thing C what this called cage diving what is
there a term for this I guess that would be
cage diving right yeah uh someone who's never
done anything underwater in the middle of the
ocean kind of deal uh this felt believable and
realistic to me till it got a little Hollywood
with that's what maybe was making me question it
the second Kate was alive was it because I was
like this is the one part of the movie that's
feeling very Hollywood to be um however I was
like but I feel like maybe the movie earned it
because for very related into the film so maybe
it turned it uh but overall as the movie went
I I found it very gripping and um appropriately
claustrophobic and I I love the Desolation to it
and it was a a great aura of suspense and and uh
you know paranoia and it was really FR tension
throughout and you it's it's like the the time
was flying by yeah so I I really really enjoyed
it uh a lot it was I was more impressed with
it I wasn't expecting to walk out saying that I
found a lot of this very impressive um there is
that one choice that I want to go into about the
ending with the hallucination that that does kind
of rub me the wrong way yeah and I'll tell you why
later but I want to hear your thoughts man I I'm a
I'm claustrophobic so those shots of her reaching
the Cliff's Edge were some of my favorites I mean
I it makes it throws you into it and with the
shots that they choose they really do make you
feel a sense of panic which is you know I Bravo
for doing that because I think they're throwing
the audience into exactly the position they want
you to be in to really feel how terrifying this is
um and then uh my favorite shot terrifi I jumped
out you could go back and Rewind it I literally
jumped out of my seat when the second flare goes
on and we see two sharks I thought it was three
or maybe it was three I don't even know my brain
was it just the whole thing amazing and also so
scary and I can't yeah that was that was such a
great shot um what an awesome reveal this was a
lot of fun and it was very grounded I mean the
two actresses did a great job oh yeah excellent
excellent yeah so so good and even at the the top
there it's like we got some Foundation of her to
for her to talk about um Stuart and whatnot and
I steuart best off camera character in the world
yeah yeah I I feel like the the beginning stuff
my of of her the only the one part that kind of
bugged me that I was like wait is this gonna be
corny when she first walked onto the dock and
she's we didn't really see the sign the sign was
just like on its side and that that's what made
her freak out where she went oh God I don't know
if I can do this and I went like but really just
cuz the sign but anyway uh that part kind of made
me giggle cuz I was like wait where are we going
with this and then where we headed was excellent
like I loved it just the top of the setup I I
thought it I I thought we were going to go into
corny cheesy land just a little bit there was a
few bits and pieces at the top once we got in the
water stuff's great I loved it it was beautiful
shots and um yeah I mean for for the ending uh
I don't know I mean maybe they're like hey we'll
actually see uh her fight out from if she goes in
the water again in 40 isn't there there's another
one right that they're like oh we'll actually show
it and she won't be hallucinating because I would
have liked to actually see I don't know her I
don't know if the sequel brings her back right I'm
like but maybe maybe she's dumb enough to go again
cuz everyone's like Mandy Mar we love you it's
probably someone else I know it but whatever yeah
I I mean yeah um it's got a high Amazon rating
though the yeah I I love the music a lot too there
was a great sense of dread and I thought the sound
design was excellent they especially a lot of this
could have been overly Punchy and super cinematic
with its sound design and here I think they wanted
to find that right balance between something that
is it's like think of it think of the balance of
trying to find the the ground between a realistic
punch and then you know because in real life
there's not cool sound effects when some when
someone gets punched you know yeah and having so
having that grounded especially when we've seen
sharks in so many movies which the Roars and the
thrashes are usually so much more enunciated and
here it's not really there which make because I
thought they had a great job on cutting between
the perspectives of I keep calling her m anymore
what's the character's name I know Kate because
I don't know the's name oh remember Lisa Lisa
hi Lisa um yeah Lisa and Kate because yeah the
like you said the relationship between them was
really strong and I I loved how you know uh Lisa
was the older sister and and and there was just
enough character to get you invested like I was
I was genuinely invested in them and I I was at
the point where I thought I was like okay I my
initial thought was pretty much what happened
that except except she yeah they kind of they
were subverting expectations in certain directions
um but that Kate would die and that she mny Moore
would make it out alive but I thought Mandy Moore
would have like her like I'm just gonna go for it
moment um which she does have but it's fake it's
a hallucination moment so yeah has it it happens
in you definitely called that yeah it's still I
it's the hallucination part it does um throw a
wrench in that big time so I thought so I thought
the actors are really good and they I thought they
did an amazing job of these because you can't
see their faces for most of it so so much has of
it has to be conveyed just in the delivery yeah
you know and and you really because in order to
feel the Panic of the situation you have to feel
what Mandy Moore is feeling and I thought whoever
played Kate wish I learn her name whoever played
Kate she has to portray um assuredness and and
strength while also clearly being ter provide at
the same time you so I thought it was really well
layered and I like the Arc of the jux that's the
part of it that bugs me about the Hallucination
is I think it really undermines Mandy Moore's
character Arc because she doesn't actually have
it she she doesn't actually grow up to go I'm
I'm now at a position where I can take care of
this on my own right and get out of it yeah and
I think they have the hallucination point because
because the hallucination happens the one part of
why I think the Hallucination is well Justified
is because when she saves herself from getting
lifted up from the cage and then Kate for some
reason is not being devoured to death it when it
becomes very Hollywood at that point and like oh
shark's attacking me and let like I but I was I
was still believing it when me too when when the
shark was attacki and then but you even pointed
out like oh they're at the surface already like
there was stuff here that was starting to question
the the a movie that was making the validity of
what we saying exactly everything was very real
until here where it was interweaving but I was so
in the suspense of the moment yeah and the hope of
the moment that I was like whatever it's a movie
and I want them to live so let's just roll with
it and then it kept having me in the tug of war I
thought was such a great scene too of oh it's got
her it's she got away oh it's got her again then
she got away like it it was doing such a great job
with the Bel with even though you had to suspect
SP your disbelief it would still pull you back in
with the with the um intensity of the situation
and the immediacy of it that everything that
was like critic critical of realism I would just
like disregard it for the sake of the emotional
catharsist that I'm feeling in this moment and
the and the grip of Terror yeah but then when you
have the hallucination reveal I felt like it was
um tragic for tragedy's sake and nothing to really
help serve the character like I think it probably
would have been better if she hallucinated and
then she died yeah because like she was just
down there looking at her blood and it that would
have been a I kind of imagine that too like it
would have been a sweet kind of a sweeter better
sweet ending where she's just seeing her blood and
she's saying like Kate we made it and it's just
we see a slow Dolly out and it's like air is just
surrounding and that's that's it we go to blackout
you just you use your imagination right having the
the sense that at least she died thinking that she
had yeah that that she was rescued yeah because
I'm like what's the point now because like then
the coast guards come just like a second later
and saver so um so to me I didn't feel like it was
NE it's like you either stick with you either just
give us the ending that you made it that they made
it out or you give us the uh an ending well that's
why I thought how are they they going to use her
for two cuz why do we have to see her still alive
I don't think she's I would not I can't imagine
she would do it again but maybe she's like I still
love Stewart man I'm trying yeah I'm trying to I
already done this I I I live yeah so I think some
PE I I just to me personally I find the choice a
bit manipulative of oh look how sad this [__] is
when I'm like no I mean it kind of undercuts your
movie and I'm it what also undercuts the tragedy
of it is she's just saved later so she just with
the fact that her sister's dead know I agree I I
think it would have been more um more sad more
bsweet if she was like I said you know she's
she's happily saying hey Kate we made it she's
at the bottom of the ocean imagining she's happy
with her sister but the reality is she's going to
die down there and her sister's long gone this by
letting her live with the coast guards pulling
her out I'm like whatever yeah yeah it doesn't
make it as exciting which is why I'm like and
also in the in the immediacy of the moment cuz
I said she's hallucinating but you said it's too
soon yeah I was like it too soon on there does
seem like timeline wise she's hallucinating
remarkably quick like in the way the movie us
away right yeah and so it did that threw me off
too but may maybe that's how it is in real life
I I I have no idea I don't know either um I also
think with the sound real quick that it was very
subdue there was a couple of times that I was
going to say I was going to be like this sounds
like a spa like when you go spot and get a massage
like it's like meditative music and uh at first I
was like oh interesting choice I feel like I'm
walking in to get a very relaxing massage but
then that that it faded quickly and I was like
oh it really just matches the serenity of what
it feels like when you're down in the ocean right
you're just surrounded by water it really actually
matched the vibe of what we were um living in ju
AOS to you are also surrounded by these kind of
killers even though I think the the great white
sharks they they don't tend to like eat humans in
full they kind they'll damage you bad to where you
could die but they don't they'll be like bye play
with you and be like you really don't taste like
seal so no thanks but um still it's terrifying
I liked uh the sound mixed with like I said J's
position of how scary we're surrounded by these
scary sharks and when they came up I think you're
right about we didn't necessarily the music didn't
change we just saw them it was revealed because we
were living in their in their space a lot which I
really enjoyed of just the breathing and like
holy crap we turn our head and there's a shark
and that made it really really scary for me which
is I think what made the intensity bigger anytime
they would go out of the cage they're surrounded
by full water it looks black dark and we're like
a shark could come at any moment and we know the
music is not going to lead us to revealing that
yeah that it's not going to be like uh I agree
because I mean we joked about it at the top um
you know like uh that because we know roxxy's um
friends with the director right and we're like
we're not GNA kiss the director's ass here and I I
never would um no I will say though like well but
the best part of the movie is the way the movie
is directed like the way the movie is shot is
is the best part of the movie like working with
the cinematographer the it is so cleverly done
because anytime they step out of the cave the
sense of surrounding is is just so incredibly
vast and dense that you and and the perspective
is so skewed and you know that that like you
can't really see so you always get a sense that
a shark will appear at any moment and they really
do a great and this is something that could have
easily broached the terrain of constantly feeling
ridiculous and feeling unbelievable but it managed
to give you just enough sense of the scope and the
distance and believability when they were able
to survive or hide from a shark and a and also
as someone who doesn't like it seemed like you
were able to keep up with a a little bit more
than I was um just because you have personal
experience with all this stuff where it was
scuba diving and whatnot and whereas I I'm like
I'm learning all this information for the first
time right but I was still able to keep up with
like the rules established of what it takes to
survive in a situation like this and so there was
a great grip on t mention the editing was very
solid everything around the film making side and
the Performing was really great it's really just
the storytelling choice of what they did with the
ending that rubbed me the wrong way um yeah the
Cinematic shots like when they would choose to
cut cuz we we deal in a lot of extreme close-ups
and extreme like not a lot but Extreme when they
would go back to the Masters and they would reveal
just them in the middle of the water or it's just
them with their flare or it's just them with those
three sharks that's wild I love how they utilize
that right where it's like we're very close in in
their world and then we we can get super far
out um which this cinematography in here was
really great overall I thought it was very I would
give it it goes down I give it like a seven out of
10 yeah I give it like a seven like 7.5 I know
was it went down for me because the ending did
not rub me the right way so that's the only thing
that brought it down for me yeah um otherwise I'd
be like an eight and a half but yeah I had like
a 7.5 for it yeah yeah I really think man if she
was just down there and she's like to seeing her
we know she's going to die down there I'd be like
oh man what a what a film like but it makes it
way it makes it so much more sad but also so much
more realistic but that then the tragedy of that
would truly hit them as opposed to this is just
like Hollywood sad like look how sad this is that
she's I mean she still gets to live but her sister
actually is dead is dead for like five minutes she
believed her sister was alive and that she was a
hero in this [__] yeah um yeah yeah I had fun
though it was fun it was a super fun movie I'm I
I did not expect it to be that good I I wasn't
sure what I was going into I really didn't cuz
like some of you know some of the shark movies are
like they're not great and this one I had a ton
of fun so thanks for making it uh any last words
nope I'm good that is it from from us we love you
so much don't forget to leave a like and a comment
and ring the bell we'll see you next [Music] time